Speaker 1: We are continuing to follow the
2022 midterms. Last week we looked at both
the Democratic and Republican primary debates in
the Pennsylvania Senate race. We will be looking
at another debate in that race Wednesday night.
I will be streaming the Republicans, including
Mehmet Oz and a bunch of other whackos are going
to be debating and we'll be covering that live.
But today, I want to talk a little bit about
Georgia. Georgia has a number of interesting
races and they involve significant controversy
in Georgia. You've got the gubernatorial election
in that. That is an important race
because of the role that Georgia played
in 2020 and could play in 2024 in the election.
And who is governor and secretary of state?
A very big deal. Marjorie Taylor GREENE
at this point wildly perjuring herself,
inciting an insurrection. She is involved in
a race for reelection and there are debates
happening there as well. And what I want you to
think about as you watch some of these clips,
there were a number of Georgia debates over
the weekend. We'll look at gubernatorial. We
will look at also Marjorie Taylor GREENE.
They seem like Saturday Night Live skits.
And I'm not just talking about the accents. I know
people in Georgia and certain parts. There's a
certain education level where there's a certain
accent that that's not what I'm talking about.
These seem like characters out of a skit
where we are pretending to be the most
weaponized, misinformed caricatures of what it
means to be an American right winger. When we
think of how do you depict your typical American
right winger in a film for a British audience,
it would be like these people. Let's go with
the first clip. This is Candace Taylor running
for the Georgia governor's race. And I let's just
listen. I won't even there's no there was really
no way to introduce this properly. Take a look.
Speaker 2: At the Constitution first, and I'm
going to put Jesus first every single time.
Speaker 1: Wait, your your guiding philosophy
will be Jesus first. You're supposed to be a
representative of the state's civil government,
which is a separation of church and state. But
she openly says Jesus will be number one for her.
Speaker 2: And we're going to fix our
schools. We're going to get rid of this
anti white racism and oppression of our
children of color. We're going get and again.
Speaker 1: CHÖDRÖN Is that is that a normal
thing? I don't want to make fun of accents,
but are these is that is that a normal thing?
Speaker 2: CHÖDRÖN Rid of the transgender
manipulation. Are we going to ensure that boys
are in our girls bathrooms and girls are in our
boys bathrooms and people aren't being raped? And
we're going to get rid of kindergarten teachers,
men with beers and lipstick in high heels,
teaching our children. We're going to get
back to being moral in Georgia. We're going to
put morality over money. I'm kind of. Taylor
I'm the one you've been waiting for.
Speaker 1: Right? That is Dark Ages stuff. And is
it even okay to say, I know sometimes people get
mad when you say Dark Ages, but that that's that
dark age stuff, that's retrograde, that's taking
us back. You know, sometimes we say they want
to take us to 1955 with some of these people.
It's almost like they want to take us to 1855
United States. Here's another clip of Candice
Taylor talking about what was going on. All of
the bad things about schools having been closed
for a period of time during the COVID pandemic.
Speaker 3: Do you do as governor?
Would you push to help address
those issues dealing with academics?
Speaker 2: Absolutely. It's gotten
way worse because of the pandemic,
because our governor opened the state,
which was great. They didn't open the schools.
Speaker 1: Now, did she say the planned
pandemic? I want to go back because that that's
another wild conspiracy. This is almost like
remember the disinformation film Plandemic, which
argued it was all planned by the globalist elite,
as Alex Jones would say, thinly veiled
anti-Semitism, by the way, because those
globalist elites happened to be mostly Jewish.
Did she say the planned pandemic? Let me listen.
Speaker 2: Gotten way worse because
of the pandemic. Because our.
Speaker 1: Plant. Maybe it was just a
stutter. It's almost like, she said,
the planned pandemic. Let's listen.
Speaker 2: An hour opened the state,
which was great. They didn't open the schools and
so kids were at home for a year. Not engrained in
education and routine. Children need routine. And
what we saw happen is children with depression
or sure that were being molested. Let's talk
about the hard stuff. Kids are being molested,
never had had a reprieve. They were molested
day after day after day. And their parents
were not teaching them anything. And so staying
consistent for one thing, and I haven't after
school programs and offering things to get them.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Now, I mean, it is it is
absolutely true that one of the things about being
stuck at home and we saw this with couples where
there's domestic violence oftentimes leaving to
work was when you got a break from the domestic
violence that that is true. But this sort
of framing completely ignoring the actual
circumstances that were happening medically
imagined, this is the governor very,
very dangerous. Next we'll go to from the Georgia
gubernatorial to Georgia 14th District. There was
a Republican primary debate. The incumbent in
that seat is radical, repugnant, reactionary
Republican Congresswoman Marjorie Taylor. GREENE
And she was in a debate with Jennifer Strayhorn.
And her behavior was so childish and so absurd
that the moderator actually had to cut her mic
because she just wouldn't stop talking.
Marjorie Taylor GREENE would not stop talking.
Speaker 3: Serve it if it takes courage, takes
bravery to vote no to bills that have poison
pills inside of them and things that should never
be passed. And that's how the Democrats running
Congress, that's how they're writing bills right
now. And that is why we need move record. I have
to also not support transgender. She doesn't
stop. She doesn't get a rebuttal. You would
have voted Friday. You say don't throw the baby
out of her. You're writing transgender surgery.
Speaker 4: Okay.
Speaker 1: Oh, wow. And then just the
relief of the silence when Marjorie Taylor GREENE
stops speaking, it's like, you know, when it's
like you're on a loud concert and it's just like,
wow, this is this is grating. This is grating.
And then all of a sudden, it goes silent and you
go, Wow. The tranquility. The tranquility, sir,
of the silence. That is what I experience when
Marjorie Taylor GREENE stops talking. So that
was totally off the rails. And then also in the
congressional debate, a guy named Eric Cunningham
is running and he tries to deliver a statement
about he will also out Jesus, everybody else.
But he weirdly like loses his train of thought
and just seems visibly confused. They're not
sending their best, my friends cutting him.
Speaker 4: I have strong core Christian
conservative values and I want to emphasize
one word in there. Christian. It's my faith
that brought me into this race, and it's my faith
that will lead me when I go to Congress to fight
some of the woke transgender. You name an agenda
that they have, they're trying to force on us.
Speaker 1: So he seems confused by his
own ideas. And of course, at this point,
these are just these the these are just
buzzwords woke. We're going to fight woke
we're going to fight. Transgender, we're going to
fight. We do it. Teacher Trump now at his rally
saying teachers shouldn't be allowed to teach
transgender. Grammatically ambiguous for sure.
Morally, morally depraved, too. So it's actually
the 2022 midterms are ramping up so quickly,
it's actually tough to keep track. I also wanted
to look at some clips from what's going on in
Arizona in some of the primary races there. Some
of these primaries are this week, by the way,
and we'll talk about that tomorrow, Tuesday. But
no shortage of cuckoo for Cocoa Puffs. People
that unfortunately, I'd love to say these people
have no shot. But Marjorie Taylor GREENE is in
Congress now, so we know they have a shot.
Let me know who you're most worried about.
You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman.
Lest anyone forget, the David Pakman show
is an audience supported program. We do the daily
program that you're listening to or watching right
now, and we do an extra show called The Bonus
Show every single weekday for our members. You can
sign up at join Packman dot com. You can also use
the coupon code. Wow, 22 to get yourself a tidy
little discount off of the cost of membership.
Join Pacman dot com is the place to sign up